in plain sight and just a friend request
away a Sky News investigation has
uncovered huge numbers of addictive
prescription drugs being illegally
offered for sale on Facebook
for you it's easy I suppose and the u.s.
social media giant has been refusing to
remove accounts even when reported by
users
well the Internet's all about
convenience and this couldn't be easier
once you know where to look you can plug
in to you a network of these dealers
online as a message out the blue a
little bit of a chat and we've stopped
short of buying drugs but if we hadn't
they be in the post right now dealers
post a photo of their stock often with a
handwritten note with the date and their
name on it
transactions are carried out in private
messages we found powerful tranquilizers
sedatives and opioids being offered on
the social network alongside Valium and
Xanax pregabalin is relatively new to
the scene but it's addictive and it's
already been linked to a number of
deaths in the UK some dealers also
offered more traditional recreational
drugs for sale including ketamine
cannabis and MDMA selling drugs without
a prescription isn't merely a question
of legality it has the potential for
serious harm people have committed
suicide as the ultimate resort to try to
get off because these keys are fiercely
addictive once you start taking them the
medicines and Healthcare Products
regulatory agency or MHRA for short is
used to seizing knockoff steroids and
viagra but sedatives are something new
these sleeping pills and the
antidepressants a lot more dangerous a
lot more addictive when in fact they are
highly addictive the reason the
prescription only so that changes the
game completely we shared our
investigation with the MHRA we also
reported more than a dozen drug dealing
accounts to Facebook they refused to
remove every single one of them saying
we've looked over the profile you
reported and although it doesn't go
against any of our specific community
standards we understand that the profile
or something the person shared may still
be offensive to you let's look at those
specific community standards we prohibit
any attempts by unauthorized dealers to
purchase sell or trade prescription
drugs marijuana firearms or ammunition
we got in touch with the Facebook press
office to ask why the dealer's accounts
apparently didn't breach their standards
even though they broke British law soon
after we emailed those accounts did turn
out to violate those community standard
after all and they were quietly removed
Facebook refused our request for an
interview later they give us this
statement buying selling or trading
prescription drugs isn't allowed on
Facebook and we urge people to use our
reporting tools if they come across this
kind of activity so we can investigate
and take swift action we're grateful to
Sky News for flagging this content to us
and have removed the pages for breaking
our standards in the meantime dealers
act with impunity I spoke with one over
the phone have you ever been in trouble
with Facebook Facebook relies on its 2
billion users to report violations
whether that's drugs extremism or abuse
even when they do plenty still falls
through the gaps Tom Cheshire Sky News